[Music]
okay everybody i am so so excited today
because i am joined by helena rayne the
director of bodies bodies bodies which
is out
now make sure you watch the film first
because we'll be talking spoilers in
this interview helena how you doing
today i'm good i'm in amsterdam where
where my hometown sort of is i also live
in new york now but this is still where
i have a little apartment and it's a
wonderful day the sun is out so it's
it's a good day
yeah i'm getting all good vibes from you
it's exciting to see and i got good
vibes from this film and i absolutely
loved it and what's interesting to me
that it is your second feature film
you're directing was there something you
learned from doing instinct that
prepared you for this film what was like
the key thing you took away from that
oh i think
um
that to me collaboration is super
important that although i really enjoy
being sort of the creator of something
and a little more in charge than i was
when i was uh acting that i still am a
true collaborator at heart
uh and that i just love you know that
that
i think a lot of people think that when
you're a director you need to know
everything and i think the key for me is
that you don't you of course need to
have a really good plan you need to be
prepared i always say like a soldier you
know as if you're going to join the
military but
in the moment it's the greatest thing is
to say what do you think or what would
you like to do or would you like to do
differently and that doesn't only go for
the actors but also for i don't know
you know the sound mixer or your dp or
cameraman or and and i truly enjoy
seeing other people sort of
blossoming and growing within this sort
of playground that i create for them
yeah and i like the playground create
here for this film and you talking about
collaborating too what i thought was
interesting was that one of my favorite
things about the film is the
performances you got out of the actors
here especially in the final act where
we're with this core four it's just
outstanding
i'm wondering though what is that
advantage you have as having so much
acting experience before directing what
what could you kind of learn from acting
that you kind of brought to your
directing i think the main thing to me
is that i know what it is to be in that
position and it of course it looks like
this really joyful thing to do and and
something that you know it almost looks
like actors want that attention and they
choose to be in the middle of it all but
actors have so much shame so i think if
you're capable as a director to make
them feel safe and also to sort of guide
them and to tell them because these were
the things that were told to me when i
was very young and i really enjoyed that
people say like the more you prepare the
better you know your lines the more
you're able to let go in the moments you
know so and often especially movie
actors or film actors can can have the
misunderstanding that is better to keep
everything fresh and for some films that
might work you know and to not learn
your lines so well and to keep but i
think it's really great if you learn to
sort of especially if you have a writer
like sarah the lab who creates music
with her language that you are really
really really thoroughly prepared and
then when you actually do it you don't
you don't panic because you think oh my
god i'm losing my lines or oh my god i
don't know where what my blocking is i
don't know where to go so the better you
rehearse and then you let go in a moment
and then you can even create space for
them to improvise or to have their own
ideas because you're so well prepared as
a director and an actor then you can
both let go and really dance you know
that tango so that's yeah
yeah and i like you mentioned the
improvising i was going to ask you about
that especially when you have someone
like a pete davidson on set was there a
lot of room in these scenes where
we didn't see even different takes you
guys had of different scenes like was
there a lot of improvising going on in
general yeah of course i think i had
very specific spaces in mind even before
we started where i was like okay here
i'm going to ask him or her
to do you know a bit of improv um so we
would always do the scene completely as
written on the page and we would you
know cover all of that and shoot all
that and then we would always do takes
in which certain people got like that
those liberties at certain specific
times so that they wouldn't you know be
in each other's ways but really could do
that and yes he brought a lot to the
table um that wasn't in the script but
also rachel senate and also amandla
stemberg like a man left for instance at
that moment where she talks about
ableist you know that
she came up with that um and so and some
of them also had ideas like you know we
would come on set with breakfast and
they would come up to me and say like
hey wouldn't it be more fun if i said
this or isn't it funnier if i do that
and um you know a lot of it was it was
actually improvised or came from them
during the table read or rehearsals
yeah and you could tell and there's like
a natural rhythm to the film where it
just feels real too so it really
immerses you in that sense as an
audience member which i love and i'm
also wondering too because you're
filming mostly in same locations did
that give you
the
easier way to do things where you filmed
chronological order most of this film or
did you kind of
film
for it gave us a lot of freedom in the
sense that we had more time because of
course if you would have to move between
you know i don't know if you have to
drive for miles to another house or
whatever so we really restricted
ourselves to really say before we found
that house like it needs to be one house
we need to find a house that is so big
and so decadent that it actually has all
those different rooms that sarah and i
created on the page
but once we were there um it was we
didn't we weren't able to shoot in the
chronological order because it just
didn't work as far as the lighting
because as you could see
so much of it is in the dark so you had
to be super creative with light because
me being an actor i've been on movie
sets where i only shot nights you know
where you don't sleep anymore and i just
didn't want that for them so i was like
we need to find tricks so that we can do
half a day half a night and so we didn't
shoot in chronological order but it was
absolutely wonderful to be all together
in that house it was covered they were
that was not wonderful but the fact that
we were all imprisoned and that we were
so close to the house in our little
hotel
i think that really helped us to create
that friendship but also to create the
feeling of being in the pressure cooker
you know that basically the crew and i
and all the actors were when we were
shooting
yeah and i i like you mentioned the
lights because i was asking about that
because of a lot of it being in the dark
you had to get creative with the
lighting and this so was it a use of a
lot of natural lighting that's even in
the scene or were there also tricks you
were using with like artificial lighting
that we weren't seeing we did use some
tricks but my dp os provolf he also
comes from the netherlands we we shot
instinct together he's a genius but he's
he's a very hardcore european which
means that he doesn't really believe in
all the artificial things so of course
we add little things but he would really
take pride in the fact that they would
actually have to light each other and
that it was you know we had moments
because the house was literally like a
crazy labyrinth so we would actually
like make it pitch black dark you know
and it was just crazy if you would go to
the toilet you'd be oh my god where am i
gonna end up
so it was actually at times we we truly
got a little scared and but it was also
very very hard for the actors to to have
to light each other because you know but
besides the fact that you have to do you
know your lines are you're reacting and
you're emotional and you're
whatever you're doing and then you have
to think oh my god i have to because i
have a head lamp on my head i have to
move my head a certain way because
otherwise my scene partner is not going
to be seen by the audience so they had
so many different things that they had
to think of but being gen z and being
able to you know think on so many
different levels and look at 600 screens
at the same time they were able to do
all of that so i was so proud of them
yeah and they all do an amazing job and
it's tribute to your great directing too
and i really like your choice of using a
lot of handheld camera work here what
went into that choice so when you were
kind of planning out in your head how
you wanted to film this thing
i think for me of course there were a
lot of challenges with this film which
mainly is the fact that you have one
location you don't and and you have all
these very long group scenes and people
forget that but this this film has so
much language in it it's almost a play
you know and sarah lab is a playwright i
come from the theater so there was a big
danger in this whole film becoming this
like you know radical art house in
except you know not
accessible intellectual things so i
think it was super important to us to
keep it visually very sensual and primal
and visceral and that's why i asked
javascript and he totally agreed to keep
that camera style very handheld and just
close to the actors and so that you know
you really feel that you're with them
there and you experience this whole
thing you start to suspect each other
you
you literally don't know anymore which
is also the truth if you play the game
mafia wearable for bodies bodies bodies
or murderer if you want to call it where
you don't know anymore what is true what
is who's lying where am i and this house
becomes a character by itself that you
know
you don't even know anymore where which
room is the map of the house becomes
very blurry as if you took some lsd and
so i always you told each other all the
time like it should be like a drug
infused trip if you know the moment that
there's a moment in the film that beast
eats the cake and they tell her you know
i hope you realize this weed cake but
you already ate like literally half the
cake right and it doesn't really make
her stone but it does make her go into
this rabbit hole like alice in
wonderland and you know and the rest is
sort of a mental trip oh totally i
definitely felt that and like you
mentioned too i like that immersive feel
like i felt like i was at the party with
them
um
also was there any choices for you as a
director when you look back that you
were like the most hung up on like was
there anything that was making you like
toss and turn at night
um oh yeah i mean you mean for me myself
like what i was nervous about yeah like
was there something you kind of just
didn't know which way to go with like
what was that thing that you were like
oh
i mean the ending i mean can we i don't
know how much we can spoil it yeah this
is spoiler yeah okay spoiler so um here
we go with spoilers so for me when i got
on board of this project i was very
intrigued by the game because i used to
play that game all the time with my
friends and it was like psychological
warfare and i thought it was a great
premise for you know a juicy character
piece
uh but the end at that time there was
still a killer uh and i was not
interested in that because for me not
because i judge it at all because i love
great films with great killers or
monsters or a haunted house or a ghost
or whatever but it's just not my style i
come from a very different background so
i'm more interested in human behavior so
the moment we had that ending where we
were actually you know we were like okay
wait a minute there is no killer you
know that was the biggest epiphany
because if there's no killer then it's
just about reaction it's just about
human behaviors how do we react to each
other and then
when we came up with the idea of the
tick-top death and of course i mean
these things really happen you know
and then as sort of a metaphor for
vanity and maybe toxic masculinity and
competition you know we thought that was
a great sort of
very banal but funny in a dark way
ending and that's when i found my key
into it but of course i was always super
stressed out because you can write this
all down like oh you know he kills
himself while he tries to open a bottle
of champagne with the serpent how do you
actually make that believable ever
so
i i lay awake i laid awake so many
nights about that i would later wake up
and the moment pete did the take that we
used in a film we all got up and we were
like
like oh that's amazing crazy seals
because we just knew
because if you don't make that if you
don't pull that off your film is [ __ ]
you know what i mean
and that and i was super nervous about
all the group scenes just coming from
another country
you know instinct those were my best
friends those actors these actors i i
just got to know i i look up to them i i
really you know i want to impress them
but i also want to give them enough
attention and to make a huge group scene
with so much language make it
you know make it suspenseful and
interesting and juicy and and and i i
just thought oh my god how are we going
to do that you know so yeah i was very
nervous for those
well it's great because all these things
you were nervous about you pulled off
and i especially love that ending and i
love that it's different i think it's
cool as the audience member you're
trying to guess who the killer is and i
think we all forget that there's a trick
you can do there is no killer and i
thought that was so shocking and awesome
um
so i also want to ask you looking back
was there any scenes
you like were really your babies where
you wish they made the film but had to
be cut maybe for time or for any other
reasons is there anything in your head
that you were like ah i wish i could
have snuck that in
there were so many they were beautiful
there was a beautiful long scene with
bee and amandla uh so sophie and b
amanda maria bakalova on the bed just in
the beginning and now we only have the
tale of that when pete walks in and are
sort of making love on the bed there was
a long dialogue before and also the
whole section the physical section of
that was longer and i thought their
acting was just insane and but for
rhythm for you know for pace we just
couldn't couldn't do it um but i love
that scene i will always love it there
was a beautiful scene
um with b maria bakalova and lee pace
craig's character at the pool at a
certain moment when she just ate the
weed cake and and she would like go to
the pool to sort of get like a little
bit of fresh air and then he would be
there in this really odd conversation
between them that i love um we're
probably going to include that um you
know when the blu-ray or whatever it is
comes out dvd so there's a couple of
more of these mo also there's the was
they used in some of the trailer the
song that they sing right before the big
dancing it's a camp song where they say
i'm strong i'm smart
we have a much longer version of that
where you see them
in a quite in a crazy way uh
dance and sing that song together so
yeah there's there's lots of material
that i would love to share with the
audience but you just have to make
choices yeah totally but that's exciting
to hear and i'm excited to see the
blu-ray come out and i wanted on that
topic too i want to say to you like just
as a film nerd and that community of
film nerds like we still love director
commentaries and i would love if you do
a director's commentary for this film or
fight for the cause because we want it
we want to hear it i already did it i
did it
and i lost it and i actually i because i
i'm a little older than you are and i
was so surprised because of course when
i was young that was normal you know and
then it disappeared so i love that 824
actually asked me to do that i was like
oh my god i didn't it was a thing again
but i so enjoyed it it so yes i that's
it's gonna be on there oh that's the
best news thank you i'm so happy to hear
that yeah because we just want more of
that and um can't wait to hear that
now also
was there a scene for you that was the
most challenging to film when you look
back that was giving you the most like
headaches let's say
we well the the the introduction in
swimming pool because you know i made up
this whole idea that they all the
characters should be underwater when
they get introduced because for me
they're in a womb blah blah blah
but of course the reality of that is
that you need to
you know actors need to to stay on the
water in order to film this we had to
make them heavier with it's a whole
thing you think oh somebody can just
float on the water but it doesn't work
like that because they flew up
that was hard and as far as acting i
think uh the big scene that you spoke
about like where you know the girls
really go full out or which speaks about
her podcast and my holla shoots her in
the leg
that scene was something we all sort of
like looked forward to but also dreaded
because it was the longest thing ever on
the page it was like 15 pages long it
was crazy and so we thought how are we
ever going to pull that off and just to
keep the humor in that moment i thought
yeah but it but it succeeded and i
that's really because of them they they
were so amazing and they never got like
tired even though the the day was so
long the night was so long we shot that
but so i'm very proud of that but that
was absolutely a scene that i was like
oh my god oh my god how are we going to
do that yeah that's great to hear too
because that was my favorite scene in
the film so it's cool to hear that that
hard work really does pay off which is
awesome and then
um is there one character here you
yourself can relate to the most was
there one that kind of spoke to you in
any way oh they all speak to me and they
are all i like to think and i hope that
the audience feels that too but for me
definitely even though people say
they're unlikable to me they're all part
of myself you know i really recognize
myself in emma the girl who's so in love
with the david's character and so
obsessed i could like that like i i have
a really soft spot for a bad man
and also the way she's like no let's not
play the game everybody's gonna cry that
was always my position with my friends
but it can also totally see myself in my
last character or jordan who's so like
no let's talk like who pays for what and
let's really organize this and we
everybody get a flashlight and get a
weapon
um and so i i relate to all of them and
b of course uh me coming to the united
states now trying to live in new york i
totally feel like that outsider trying
to make new friends at 46. yeah i'm like
oh my god how am i ever going to belong
to this group so for me all of and of
course the the older guy craig is me too
like how do you play like you know he
has a grandmother being like hello can i
join this young group so no all of them
speak to me
yeah i love that i love to hear the
director having such a connection to
their characters now
before i let you go my last question for
you is
basically what is the ultimate maybe
feelings or thoughts you wanted the
audience to have after seeing this film
like what did you want us to be like
coming out of that theater well i think
the first feeling for me personally is
like what you know because it's so
it is like on purpose of course
nihilistic lame you could even call it
like it's just like a big balloon and
all the air flows out and i love that so
i think but i hope in the end that you
had a good time that you had some laughs
and that you maybe have a little bit of
thought about you know what we are
capable
as far as group behavior you know how we
sometimes just i think the truth this is
of course a more a dark comedy than a
horror but the horror of the thing to me
is human behavior you know where
misunderstandings can lead to something
like this and also just
i often compare them to a school of fish
you know there's one
yeah the whole group goes that way and
they're not actually looking at what's
going on because they're constantly
glued to their phone screen and when the
wi-fi goes out the demons come in so
i hope that it maybe will provoke some
discussion but mainly of course i hope
to entertain people and just make them
laugh and make them feel something and a
little bit afraid but also just this
haunting feeling of this weird trip and
this weird house you know so i hope they
enjoyed themselves yeah hell yeah and
you know everyone listen to this
interview go see it again tell your
friends about it make sure to see it in
theaters first then get hyped for the
blu-ray it sounds like it's gonna be a
lot of cool stuff with it helena thank
you so much for joining me today and i
hope to talk to you again in the future
thank you so much i love this
conversation it was really amazing thank
you so much for having me you're very
very kind thank you oh thank you
appreciate you